[Música]
pocas especies en el planeta comparten
un rasgo Aparentemente misterioso el
ciclo menstrual somos uno de los pocos
elegidos mono simios murciélagos humanos
y posiblemente musarañas elefante Son
los únicos mamíferos terrestres que
menstrúan también lo hacemos más que
cualquier otro animal a pesar de ser una
pérdida de nutrientes y puede ser un
inconveniente Entonces cuál es el
sentido de este proceso la respuesta
comienza con el embarazo cuando los
recursos del cuerpo se usan hábilmente
para crear un entorno adecuado para el
feto Un refugio interno para que la
madre pueda nutrir a su niño en
crecimiento a este respecto el embarazo
es impresionante pero eso es solo la
mitad de la historia la otra mitad
revela que el embarazo pone a la madre y
a su hijo en pugna como todo ser
viviente el cuerpo humano evolucionó
para promover la propagación de sus
genes para la madre esto es intentar
abastecer Igualmente a toda su
descendencia pero una madre y su feto no
comparten exactamente los mismos genes
el feto hereda genes de su padre también
y esos genes pueden promocionar sus
propios genes extrayendo más recursos de
su madre
este conflicto de intereses evolutivo
pone a la mujer y a su hijo por nacer en
pie de guerra biológica dentro del útero
un factor que contribuye a esta pelea
interna es la placenta el órgano fetal
conectado al suministro de sangre de la
madre y que nutre al feto mientras crece
en la mayoría de los mamíferos está tras
una barrera de células maternas
esta Barrera permite el control del
suministro de nutrientes al feto pero en
humanos y en otras pocas especies la
placenta penetra en el sistema
circulatorio de la madre para acceder
directamente a su torrente sanguíneo a
través de la placenta el feto bombea
hormonas a las arterias de la madre para
abrirlas y asegurar un flujo permanente
de sangre rica en nutrientes un feto con
dicho acceso puede fabricar hormonas
para aumentar el azúcar en la sangre de
la madre dilatar sus arterias y aumentar
su presión arterial
la mayoría de los mamíferos expulsan o
reabsorben embriones si es necesario
pero en humanos una vez que el feto se
conecta al torrente sanguíneo cortar esa
conexión puede generar una hemorragia si
el feto se desarrolla mal O muere la
salud de la madre está en peligro
conforme crece el feto en busca de
recursos puede provocar fatiga intensa
alta presión sanguínea y enfermedades
como diabetes y preeclampsia debido a
estos riesgos el embarazo es siempre una
enorme y a veces peligrosa inversión
por eso Es lógico que el cuerpo examine
los embriones para detectar Cuáles
merecen El desafío aquí entra en juego
la menstruación el embarazo comienza con
un proceso de implantación donde el
embrión se incrusta en el endometrio que
recubre el útero el endometrio
evolucionó para dificultar la
implantación de manera que solo los
embriones sanos puedan sobrevivir pero
al hacerlo también selecciona los
embriones vigorosamente más Invasores
creando un ciclo de retroalimentación
evolutiva
el embrión tiene un diálogo hormonal
complejo exquisitamente sincronizado que
transforma el endometrio para permitir
la implantación
Qué pasa cuando un embrión no pasa la
prueba todavía podría lograr adherirse o
ingresar parcialmente a la endometrio
mientras muere lentamente podría dejar a
su madre vulnerable a infecciones y
podría emitir señales hormonales que
alteren sus tejidos
el cuerpo evita este problema
simplemente eliminando cada posible
riesgo cada vez que la ovulación No
termina en un embarazo saludable el
útero se deshace de su revestimiento
endometrial junto con óvulos no
fecundados enfermos moribundos o
embriones muertos ese proceso de
protección se conoce como menstruación y
lleva el periodo
este rasgo biológico por extraño que sea
nos pone en camino para continuar la
raza humana
ahora que sabe cómo menstrúan los
mamíferos de la tierra a continuación
descubra con este video las increíbles
formas en que diferentes especies dan a
luz y no olvides suscribirse a nuestro
canal para no perderse otro video